an anti-transgender mom was interviewed
on CNN it uh is extraordinarily
disturbing and sad and I'm gonna play it
for you and we're going to talk through
some of the things that were said this
is Darcy shoning the chapter chair for
moms for Liberty in El Paso County
Colorado uh Darcy is very very worried
she's worried that there are multiple
forces at play that want to convince our
children to become gay or trans which I
feel like a even saying because
anybody who understands being gay or
trans realizes that this concept makes
absolutely no sense nor does the nor do
any of the parties mentioned have any
interest in convincing people to be gay
or trans however what I what I do want
to point to in this interview is the
interviewer El Reeve asks why would
teachers unions abide why would they
want to convince people to be gay or
trans Darcy has an answer
it's an idiotic answer it's an easily
debunkable answer it's an answer that
makes no sense whatsoever unless you
understand nothing about anything but
she has an answer so we're going to be
able to analyze it for what it is all
right let's take a listen to this behind
your parents back I got your back I mean
there's a clear move to bring more of
that into our school then it's just not
the school's place so
what I feel like you're strongly
implying and I would like to get your
take on because I don't want to
attribute something that you don't think
but to me it sounds like you're saying
there's some kind of high level
coordinated effort to make more children
trans and gay yeah
well who's directing that teachers
unions and
um our president and a lot of funding
sources and which she doesn't mention so
that's teachers unions
our president which at least she
acknowledges Biden as the president
teachers unions Biden and a lot of
funding sources want to make kids gay
and
transunions are also happy
have they
yeah
because it breaks down the family unit
which breaks down traditional
conservative values it breaks down a lot
of things in this country it changes the
way that people think it changes the way
that people handle politics of course
there's no evidence of a coordinated
plot to make kids trans
when I hear the
like some sort of conservative
conspiracy theory to you
um it's not a conspiracy theory that
the state whether you're talking about
Colorado or the federal government is
taking a stronger and stronger hand in
public education in raising our kids
there's a big jump from that
to what she's claiming so do I think
that
for some reason people want everyone to
be gay that's a mischaracterialization
of what I think I think that people will
use you know the people that want to
erode away at parental rights the left
the teachers unions they'll use lgbtq or
whatever may be the case at the time
those are yeah so she's like it's not
that they want to make everyone gay or
trans they just want to make a lot more
people gay and trans and the critical
line from this is she says that because
it's a good question right why would
anyone want to do this what's the
political goal in making more people gay
and trans kids if you could do such a
thing and she says it will break down
the family unit and it will break down
conservative values well what's
interesting about I mean think that
through
right
if you have a child
and the child is gay
it only breaks down the family unit if
the parents reject the kid and kick them
out of the house which sometimes happens
right when you actually think about what
she's saying you realize that's only the
case if we treat LGBT folks terribly
including LGBT kids so let's go through
a couple of these these ideas here first
is the notion that teachers unions have
adopted this secret mission to undermine
the family unit and conservative values
by trying to convince children to take
on these identities there's no evidence
of that but the suggestion would make
you believe or suggest to you that
Educators who go through all of the
schooling that they go through
bachelor's degree typically master's
degree they learn how to teach how to
impart knowledge how to uh uh educate
young minds all of these things
their actual plan all along was to be
social Engineers to get themselves into
classrooms in order to convince children
to be gay specifically to tear families
apart by destroying the fan family unit
through such social engineering that's
an insane thing to accuse teachers of
doing because you have to when they
vaguely say the teachers union
you you think of this monolith this
almost like a corporation of sorts but
then you think through and you go oh
okay the third grade teacher who is now
in debt because of the Masters in
Education that they have and they're
underpaid and blah blah blah they did
all of it not because they genuinely
want to teach kids but because they have
this clandestine mission to turn kids
gay and trans and that's how they want
to shape the country through social
engineering it's an outrageous thing to
suggest then there's will Biden wants
the same thing
I I mean you know if if anything can be
said about Joe Biden it's that his focus
on LGBT issues has not been overwhelming
I mean yes he's done a couple events at
the White House and welcomed people or
whatever he's treating people with with
respect but the idea that that's Biden's
goal but also the idea that that this
alleged obsessive focus on turning
people kids gay and trans by Biden would
gain him political Capital when it's
known to be such a controversial issue
thanks to right Wingers that doesn't
make any sense in any way and then
lastly she throws in this and there are
also funding sources that want more gay
and trans people
she doesn't name those sources I think
unless she does it's very hard to take
it seriously but you you have to
understand what's at this core
a very benign and milk toast
sort of Declaration that we should treat
people with respect we should have basic
inclusivity in schools when it comes to
LGBT people like that's what's really
going on like let's treat people with
respect in some places we have to figure
out what to do about bathrooms because
it's like a tactical issue a practical
issue yes and some there are some sports
related questions to figure out but
basically what we're saying is let's let
everybody feel comfortable
and let's prevent people from feeling
under threat based on their identity
because that's what gives those folks
and as a result society as a whole the
greater chance to flourish and provide
everybody equal rights and opportunities
under the law that's that's all that's
going on
and they see that as an attack
they see it as an attack on quote
conservative values they see it as an
attack on the quote family unit as Darcy
shoning says in this interview
that's what this is really about
leveling the playing field so that it's
not openly okay to discriminate against
minority groups they see as an attack
and that tells you a lot about what
these folks are thinking people often
ask me about my daily routine you know
I'm interviewed about the David packman
show how did you do it how do you do
this and like daily routine just often
comes up and how do you stay healthy and
of course I talk about exercise and I
talk about eating the right diet but one
of the things that can happen if you are
not eating the right diet or you're
traveling or life gets in the way is you
end up with some kind of vitamin
deficiency a daily scoop of ag-1 from
our sponsor athletic greens makes this
super easy to take off of your list of
things to worry about one scoop of ag1
you get the entire day's worth of 75
high quality vitamins and minerals from
Whole Food sourced ingredients ag1 is
cheaper than dealing with a bunch of
different supplements it's infinitely
more convenient you just take a scoop
before you have your coffee for example
as I do in the morning and you're
covered for the entire day many of my
friends love ag1
anyone I mention it to seems to get
hooked when I go on vacation I bring the
ag1 travel packs with me especially
because I'm not always eating the same
diet when I'm traveling that I do at
home staying properly nourished so
important to feeling your best ag1 just
makes it really easy and very convenient
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman to get a
free year supply of vitamin D I've
talked about vitamin D so many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below